we're now firmly in the middle of
smartphone season something new being
announced almost every week this is the
Moto X style and it's a large powerful
phone with a refreshingly small price
tag with its new top-of-the-line phone
Motorola decided to go big and I mean
really big the Moto X style has a 5.7
inch quad HD display putting it toward
the upper edge of the smartphone
spectrum however it has really slim
bezels and the curved profile and small
dimple on the back help make it easy to
hold even for those of us with small
hands if you're not yet a convert to the
large phone you should be and this is
one of the easier ones teams across the
board performances snappy and videos
look great Motorola adds just a few
small features to Android like special
notifications and voice assist all of
which are helpful without getting in the
way of the Queen experience Google
intended the big question going into
this review though with the camera which
is where Moto's phones usually fall
short the 21 megapixel shooter launches
with two flicks of the wrist focuses
quickly and takes really great pictures
if it's not the very best smartphone
camera it certainly amongst the top view
battery life is another place where this
phone shines I had no problems getting
through a full day and with extra fast
turbo charging I got a few extra hours
of juice out of just 10 minutes on the
charger this alone is a big draw no
phone is perfect though and the Moto X
style does have its drawbacks the
headphone jacks on the top of the phone
which results in some awkward cable
management and I had issues getting my
unit to pair with bluetooth headphones
which was a major disappointment there's
also no fingerprint reader which means
unlocking your phone and Bob's pass
codes and it could be an even bigger
issue ones Android pay rolls out
starting at 399 the Moto X style comes
in is just over half the price of
Samsung's Galaxy Note 5 and Apple's
iPhone 6 plus and it's only available
unlocked which means quicker software
updates and no nonsense from carriers at
this price it's a total steal and it
makes a strong case for moderately
priced unlocked phones becoming the norm
you